hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show
so if you're like me then possibly your
first introduction to the field of
biogear ontology
is the 2013 review article the hallmarks
of aging
by lopez otto natal this most cited
review in the field of aging defines
common denominators of aging and
different organisms
and puts them into nine different
hallmarks and is a pretty common
reference point for the field
i've always liked the hallmarks as an
introduction to the fields
so much so that i described the
hallmarks in some of my earliest videos
and speaking of my earliest videos given
that it's almost my two-year birthday on
youtube
i thought i'd revisit the hallmarks of
aging given that there has been some
recent criticism on them
suggesting that maybe we should start to
look beyond them
so in this video i'll first explain why
models and paradigms are useful to
scientific research
and then show you the different models
used to explain aging
as the hallmarks is not the only model
that has been proposed
and then we'll look at the limitations
of the hallmarks as discussed in this
recent critique paper
and lastly look at their solution and
just to let you know i've also made this
video in tandem with life extend show
whose video you can check out here so
the first thing we need to talk about
is why paradigms are really useful for
scientific research
and while a paradigm is basically a
pattern or model or something
but the more scientific version as
defined by the historian of science
thomas kuhn
in his book the structure of scientific
revolutions
he defines scientific paradigms as
universally recognized scientific
achievements
that for a time provides model problems
and solutions for a community of
practitioners
which is basically the idea that mature
fields of science possess effective
paradigms
which are foundations of understanding
that not only explain diverse phenomena
but can also engender a shared
perspective for communities of working
scientists
and so examples of scientific paradigms
would include the periodic table
the atomic structure mendel's laws of
genetics and the central dogma
and so this definition helps us to
understand why scientific paradigms are
really important for research
they outline what is to be observed and
scrutinized
it enables us to see what kind of
questions are to be asked and probed for
answers in relation to the subject
it also helps to understand how these
questions are to be structured
and what predictions can be made by the
primary theory it also shows
how the results should be interpreted
and how an experiment should be
conducted
so the bottom line is that at least in
my opinion a paradigm helps you to
understand a complex topic
and having an effective paradigm enables
progress to be made in a field so
effectively
scientists trust the paradigm and solve
scientific puzzles
within the rules of the paradigm more
from that it helps with science
communication
since everyone is on the same page using
shared vocabulary and help scientists
collaborate and work together
it helps to unify disciplines and
enables you to build upon each other's
results
so do we have a paradigm then for
biogerontology
the study of the biology of aging so in
this case
a paradigm for aging would be a paradigm
that could be used to understand the
biological mechanisms of aging
and how they give rise to late life
diseases so let's take a look at the
hallmarks of aging then
and so as i said earlier in this review
paper they describe
aging by nine key hallmarks and so you
can see all of these nine key hallmarks
here
and so if some of them don't make any
sense to you as i said earlier i have
made a previous video where i
do briefly introduce each of the
hallmarks so just to read them out here
we've got
genomic instability telomere attrition
so shortening of telomeres
epigenetic alterations so referring to
how chromatin is packaged in the nucleus
of a cell
then there is loss of proteostasis so
referring to protein
unfolding and protein aggregation
deregulated nutrient sensing
which refers to mtor and insulin
signaling
mitochondrial dysfunction so
mitochondria being up
the powerhouse of the cell cellulosin
essence which
um if you've watched any of my recent
videos you should know all about
stem cell exhaustion and altered
intercellular communication
and so it's worth mentioning here that
these hallmarks of aging were built upon
some of the previous hypotheses to
explain the aging process
that are summarized in this figure here
but you can see that over time there was
accumulating evidence to support the
function
of replicative senescence damage through
reactive oxygen species
evolutionary theories and through
fasting
and the authors of this critique paper
describe these early hypotheses as
experiencing a paradigmatic crisis
which refers to the crisis stage in
thomas coon's
paradigm theory and so this crisis stage
refers to the stage
whereby accumulating evidence no longer
fits with the current paradigm
such that a new paradigm needed to be
built upon
or modified but it's also worth noticing
that around the early 2000s
albert de grey also published this
theory for aging which was based on
seven
i guess you can call them paul marks but
seven different
damages that were causing the aiding
process and so this is described
in a lot of detail in aubrey's book
which i am still currently reading and
making my way through slowly
but as you can see there's quite a bit
of overlap between
his ideas and the hallmarks of aging as
you can see it includes the ideas of
mitochondrial mutations
the accumulation of junk which coincides
with the loss of proteostasis
the genomic instability which relates to
nuclear mutations
and then the stuff referring to outside
cells relates to the
loss of intercellular communication
anyway if we come back to this critique
article
what they are trying to assess is can we
consider the hallmarks of aging
as a paradigm for the field by
gerontology
and so as we learned earlier on about
the definition of paradigms
it's something that can be used as
communication in the field
so for example if i was going to tell
you about my research p53
i could kind of legitimize my
contribution to aging
by going p43 is involved in cellular
senescence and this is one of the
hallmarks of aging
so it helps to put the audience at ease
and give them some kind of familiarity
and this is because everyone in the
field knows what you're talking about
and so you can see how it snowballs in
size as more people join the field
legitimize their work and so on but the
interesting thing is that i'm actually a
cancer researcher which is convenient to
mention at this point
because the hallmarks of aging appear to
mimic the hallmarks of cancer
which was published before the hallmarks
of aging by hannah hannah weinberg in
2000
before getting updated in 2011. and i
know that this maybe sounds a bit like a
side step
but it's brought up in this critique
article because the whole muscle cancer
seems to serve as a much better paradigm
for cancer
than the homostasion does for aging so
what are their reasons to explain this
well i'm going to more or less quote
from their critique article
but in the hallmarks of cancer the
primary cause of cancer
is mutations of tumor suppressor genes
that actually include my favorite
protein p53
but other proto-oncogenes and it's these
mutations that give rise to six
other secondary causes and it suits six
other secondary causes that are
considered in the hallmarks diagram
and so it doesn't actually include
mutations as being a hallmark
because it's kind of assumed as a given
and so the formalization of the
hallmarks
is such that you have a primary
mechanism that then can cause a variety
of different secondary mechanisms
and it's the secondary mechanisms that
are the hallmarks
and this gives rise to disease and so
what the hormones of cancer achieves
is a way to explain how a wide variety
of different mutations because different
cancers
can arise from different genetic
mutations but can give rise to a variety
of cancers
by acting through a subset of these
secondary mechanisms
and so the authors of this critique
paper argue that hanahan and weinberg's
account
uses hallmarks that have considerable
explanatory power
whereby a small number of features whose
combined action can make sense for great
diversity
in both upstream primary mechanisms so
in this case mutations affecting many
genes
and downstream disease so different
cancer types
and so unlike the hormonal cancer the
hallmarks of aging include
primary secondary and tertiary
mechanisms
so the secondary ones would be the
antagonistic hallmarks
and the tertiary mechanisms are the
integrated hallmarks
and so their primary causes effectively
mirror the multiple causes of somatic
mutations
seen in the hallmarks of cancer and
actually this is one of the first points
that they make
whereby cellular damage is assumed to be
the main causal common denominator of
aging
but this is not certain and more on from
that they argue that there's
unproven claims about how the secondary
causes are arising from the primary
causes
as that is what their structure implies
and more and from that
it seems unclear what other causes of
the primary causes
as in what causes the loss of
proteastasis or the epigenetic changes
are they stochastic or programmatic and
they question why deregulated
nutrient sensing isn't also considered a
primary cause
as you can get deregulation of nutrient
sensing that doesn't necessarily result
from damage
and then lastly they argue it seems
unclear how secondary and tertiary
courses give rise to aging
and that this list of tertiary and
secondary causes
also seems a bit arbitrary and that
there are other factors that could
easily have been mentioned
such as some of the ones on aubrey de
grace list or other causes such as
inflammation immune essence leading to
increased infection
dysbiosis of the microbiome and i would
argue that
disruption of circadian rhythms should
also be added
so to summarize their criticism they say
that
the hormones of aging is problematic for
several reasons
firstly the hormones of aging
incorrectly gives an impression of an
understanding of aging that does not yet
exist
and that a true paradigm provides a
framework of understanding that guides
research
into understanding the subject that it
addresses and in terms of
understanding the causes of aging the
hormones of aging scheme has relatively
little to offer
except as a review of different aspects
of the aging fields
and as such it is excellent and this is
because it is not a paradigm in the
proper sense
instead they would consider the
hallmarks of aging a studio paradigm
so what would be their solution well
they argue for a more
multi-factorial view of aging in terms
of the distinct types of primary
mechanisms
and to account for multiple types of
primary mechanisms
as opposed to using the cancer hallmarks
where you've got one main primary
mechanism
you would need a multi-cause template
rather than a single cause one
and you can see their templates here in
this figure and so in this type of
templates there are multiple classes of
primary cause
which combine in different ways and
contribute to differing
extents to generate specific diseases of
aging
and so if you didn't completely follow
that part of the reason is that at the
moment
aging is still kind of poorly understood
and still differs in the way that it's
defined
and so what are my opinions on all this
well i think it's good to challenge a
paradigm
as it makes you think about something in
a different way and i like to think that
a good scientist is always open to new
ideas if there is supporting evidence
and so i think it's always been known
that the hallmarks of aging is not
perfect
but so far they've held up pretty well
even though they were published around
eight years ago
but as i've learned more about the
fields myself i've learned of different
explanatory mechanisms to explain aging
such as the informational theory of
aging that davids and clyde talks about
which to explain briefly is the idea
that aging is loss of information
and that if we can identify the factors
that are responsible for the loss of
information
or the ones that record the data that's
lost it would help us to better identify
ways of treating aging
and i kind of lost track of why the
sentence was heading but the main thing
i wanted to say was
as i emphasized so much in the beginning
having a paradigm
is so important for a field as to a
large extent it dictates what's
researched and how that research data is
interpreted
and it can also inspire new ideas and
also very useful for science
communication and
understanding a concept that is
notoriously quite hard to understand
and so i'm certain that having a good
paradigm for aging would really help to
boost the fields even further
and even though it seems to be doing
quite well at the moment anyway
but i guess the question is what do you
think
have the hallmarks helps you to
understand the field better or
would you have alternative ideas and
maybe we can create
sheikhi's theory of aging i'm joking um
although technically maybe i
have created one through all of my
videos somehow
and i haven't noticed that who knows
anyway
i hope you have found this video
entertaining and that you were able to
follow
the arguments remember to check out life
extend shows video
as well as they probably have done a
better job at explaining it to my health
so thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening